I think given that this is all in
litigation I'd rather not speak too much
about those property owners who have not
yet sold to us and just say we're moving
utilities and we're moving forward on my
brain behavior and the lantern building
which is School of the Arts and we'll
see how things go from here please my
observation my observation financial the
giving chart and a couple of other ones
that we talked about is that we have not
done in my view as great a job of tying
together or integrating alumni Affairs
now I'm talking about Roma outside of
the Georgian alumni affairs giving and
the admissions process and so the
challenge from my standpoint I think it
would help to raise the bar on all of
those activities is you know think of
alumni relations sort of sales and
marketing right we're the front line of
it out in the field how do you create a
holistic situation in these remote
cities where all of the people involved
in giving alumni affairs and admissions
and then sort of student management are
really on the same page and are all part
of the same team I don't really see that
happening right now
did could everybody hear that comment
yeah I couldn't agree with you more and
I think we're just now beginning to
think about you know what how we can
build these programs especially outside
New York I mean the reality is in a
Columbia everything in alumni
development has been pretty New York
centric and we haven't done as much
regionally I mean our chair of the
trustees Bill Campbell from Silicon
Valley if you've ever heard him talk
about that you know he makes these jokes
about being one of the you know guys
from the west coast and but in his sense
of that we've got to be doing more
outside of New York um and there's that
need some very specific things we can do
in that regard and I think you need to
keep saying that to us too because I do
know we've talked about even the
connection with the admissions
interviewers and that whole process and
the Alumni Relations process about doing
more so let's work on that please
there than ever the dirt on that staffs
recently told that they don't want any
people from this school to be involved
with the CAA flow
and so I'm a little confused I see
removing in both directions at the same
time I think part of the problem is
murky what the relationships between
these different groups so and that and
I'm really really sorry to hear that I
mean that's not something that I've
heard about through the grapevine or
whatever so let's just be real blunt
about all this yeah i think as all of
you know in this room the university
abdicated its responsibility for
university alumni relations for some
period of time and that's what i was
talking about in the beginning and the
school's if they wanted to have a strong
alumni program had no recourse but to
build their own siloed programs and some
of them have done a really fine job at
doing that so you know seven years when
the leak comes back in and says now now
we're ready for the university to
embrace the alumni those schools
naturally are going wait a second how
are you going to add value to what we're
doing and are you trying to take over
what we're doing and there we are you
thinking we're going to go out of
business over time I think typically the
university is the beginning and then the
school's build up under it and it's
easier than to figure out what the
relationships are we're going about it
kind of the backwards way where some of
the schools have been very strong and
now we're trying to figure out what is
the CAA thing mean and I think it is
still a work in progress somehow though
if we don't all approach this with a
positive attitude that we can make it
work and if we continue to be protective
and insular about our individual pieces
we are doomed to fail as a university
and I cannot say that strongly enough
and I would sit with the Dean of that
school and to have a long conversation
about that I got to tell you the
trustees by this lee talked about it
last night the sort of sense that you
can have a strong relationship to your
school that is an affiliation that will
never go away but it's part of your
overall relationship to columbia
university so anyway Jim let me also add
that I think the Alumni by this yeah I
think that it's extremely important for
us to acknowledge
that as time goes by after we graduate
from whatever school despite our
allegiance to that school our needs as
alums change our career needs begin to
focus and so if you are in real estate
or you're in health care or the law
you're not particularly interested in
making networking connections only with
the lungs from the school you graduated
from that happened to be in that field
you're interested in using Columbia as a
source of networking and advancement and
connection irrespective of where those
other alums have graduated from I think
socially and culturally as we grow a bit
older and I don't mean old but as we are
no longer 20-somethings at least then
they may be in this economy even
including the 20-somethings with respect
to networking but as our interest change
socially and culturally and there are
ways to connect with alumni around the
arts and entertainment and travel and
intellectual pursuits again from an
alums perspective I hear this all the
time this is something they are very
interested in the fact that the CAA can
bridge these sorts of gaps across
schools the schools that do this well
but also for them frankly for the alums
who come from schools that do not do
this well we also have some very weak
alumni organizations at some of the
schools so i think that the challenge
that susan has identified as very real
but our voices need to be heard within
those schools and this is a great
opportunity for you and others to
influence the sort of dynamic that that
susan has just described it's a really
good point i would just say the new
alumni survey that's come out where we
tried to find out more about what alumni
mean when they say they want more career
services support from the University one
of the clear findings was I want career
services that is not just school focused
for me
I want it I'm I want to be able to move
across school lines I mean that was and
again I think the Alumni speaking I
think that's exactly the right point Jim
exactly local job on the endowment
versus others like questions of the
private equity valuation still a little
concern I have is when i hear a ten
percent goal on investment returns and
all the expenditures maybe an
appropriately i'm reminded of a story
winston churchill teaching of course of
cambridge and came to class and said
what part of the human anatomy grows 12
times when exposed to external
stimulation called on a woman and she
sort of blushed and said up the middle
sexual gives it wrong but when someone
else and said the pupil of the eye when
it's exposed to darkness he said correct
went back the first woman say young lady
three things on my comment on one you
didn't do your homework to you've got a
dirty mind and third you're doomed to a
life of unbeatable expectations i'm a
little worried on the expenditure
programs and how one gets any ten
percent and returning what the risk of
them there because this God most
just learning on more debt we've had 27
years of down interest rates which a lot
of refinancing possibilities higher
asset multiples what are the causalities
and the thought process here both on the
expenditures particularly the larger
campus once one dives we can't go back
to the diving board how do you temper
this or have different proposals and how
you reevaluate the process on a
sequential basis so I one of the things
that we wanted to make sure we got to
today and I realize we haven't talked
about is what we've done differently in
the last year given the economic
circumstances and so what we haven't we
I think we've given you may be a picture
that's a little too rosy because in fact
we've all gone through a lot of
belt-tightening university-wide we've
been fortunate that we've been able to
keep so many people employed it's been
fantastic but that was because Robert
and the financial people a year ago
really jumped on the economic situation
early and forced all of us to slow our
spending even in the in the last
academic year but we've done a lot of we
taken a lot of steps to understand what
it means now to live within our means
and where Robert makes a joke to me
about raising money from manhattanville
every time he says that I feel the
pressure you know more and more on my
shoulders because we're committed to
going ahead with these projects as we're
able to afford them and they think
that's a really key point on that yep
I'm glad you feel the pressure I do i do
think we're living in a world and now
i've talked about this a moment to go in
a in a different context we're living in
a world of comparative performance and
Nora was talking about it with respect
to investments but I want to make a
broader when I said I never thought I
would dream of a negative sixteen
percent return it was partly tongue and
she
but that's a lot of loss of money and
across this university we have found
ourselves in an odd position in that the
University and I am NOT an alum I joined
the university no to my wife is an alum
but I've been watching Columbia for a
long time the university has finally and
I mean that with a sense of almost
exhaustion finally claimed its future
and just when that's all coming into
line the financial markets collapse we
came through intact many of the things
that make up made us the weakest of our
peers have left us among the strongest
of our peers I never thought I would be
bragging to rating agencies that only
twelve percent of our operating budget
comes from endowment support but that's
really a nice place to be right now and
as a result not only has nerves
outperformance helped us but it's
outperformance on a smaller slice of our
operating support we have a terrific
board of trustees and they wouldn't
tolerate and I wouldn't propose capital
projects that we don't know how to pay
for I don't want to cast aspersion that
any peer institutions but there will not
be holes in manhattanville that get
covered up unless it's by choice because
sometimes you choose to dig a bit
further and wait because it's less
expensive but we have a standard on our
capital projects which is quite rigorous
we need to know how we're paying for
them before we start them we've come
through this passage intact if there's
another leg down there will be more pain
but I believe we will come through that
intact columbia university is at an
extraordinary inflection point we're no
longer worried about whether we have the
money to pay the bills we've got a
management structure across the
university and Joe spoke about this a
couple of moments ago when he talked
about central core I don't think he
meant low library itself as the center
it's more of the sins of the there's a
cohesion to the way we're operating we
have a lot of work to do I mean I know
the list of Horrors
of things that I'm not going to brag
about in front of a video that we still
have to fix but but we are at that
inflection point and whether we as a
university rise rapidly or more slowly
because of the economy we will continue
to get better through the generosity of
the people you all represent through the
hard work they represent and because we
now have property where the scientist
dreaming about how to cure the range of
diseases that afflict our family
ourselves our friends will have a space
to do that research so it's a tough
moment it may sis continue to be a tough
moment but the future today looks very
different from what it looked like just
a short time ago please
but I personally feel that I'm strong
I
they do one more question for the back
somewhere I don't see the person but I
see a hand on the aisle yes please
I didn't android it yep Oh No Oh on the
same language I'm sorry obvious could
graduate school of architecture
preservation and planning they are
putting together their school's alumni
association so they're holding off on us
giving us some names of Representative
not for lack of cooperation I think yeah
sorry about that Miss everything let me
close by thanking all of you that
whether you're writing big checks and or
giving your time or referring the bright
kit in your high school to Columbia we
really rely upon the hard work you're
doing on our behalf thank you